bismillah alhamdulillah
assalamualaikum greetings of peace we're
here with the president of ask a Muslim
because if you have any doubts you have
any concerns any fears you should ask
the Muslims and I'm here with dr. Marwan
Salam alaikum peace be with you what a
coastal avocado you guys have doing
you're doing some great work and you
produce some of these videos that are
asking some tough questions and also
cleaning up the misconception is there's
one video that you have Thomas salvation
right and everybody at the end smart
people they realize we're gonna die
we're gonna leave this life what's the
purpose of life and now the concept of
salvation and Islam is pretty clear and
other religions it might not be so clear
what is you know this concept that's so
strong compared in contrast to what's
out there being propagated in other face
in Islam have not propagated any new
concept of salvation it's pretty much
the concept of salvation that that God
have ordained to all of the previous
prophets in the past and through Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him in which that
there is a direct relationship between
the servant and the creator and there's
no intermediary between them if you want
to ask for forgiveness then you ask to
create greater yes the creator for
forgiveness and give it your God is most
merciful most gracious he could he's
all-powerful he could forgive if you ask
for forgiveness and that's the basic
concept of salvation in Islam I mean
it's straightforward it didn't take much
explaining the one who created you you
ask him to guide you him if you make a
mistake is the one that you turn to to
forgive your mistakes no intermediaries
but if someone says look no no you you
Moslems you got it wrong God He sent His
only begotten Son to die for your sins
and if you don't believe that Jesus died
for your sins he was the sacrifice
sacrificial that you're going to
Hellfire we respect that you got a
respect someone loves you they're
bringing this to you but we can kindly
object and how would you go ahead and
answer this well there is a simple
concept in Islam oh no what allah
subhanaw taala would say well it does
you
Otten was wrong that no one can bear the
sins of another person you know that's
the basic concept in which that I cannot
carry the sin of somebody else you know
I'm only going to be responsible for my
own son you know this is something again
it's lamb did not really invent this
this is something that you even is gonna
see in the Old Testament verses in the
book of Deuteronomy in the chapter of
16:6 you know it talks about that the
father the son cannot carry the sins of
the father and the father does not carry
the sins of the son so this is something
that is pretty much the same exact verse
almost that is being that we could open
the Old Testament we could see that in
which that you know that is there is
nothing in you you know anybody could
look at it Deuteronomy 24 for go look it
up it says it's the same same exact
thing and you know so therefore if you
know if I have I am sinning you know I
am the weak person I have I have did
something against what God has asked me
to do why should I ask to go through
some other loopholes for Medicaid to
gain salvation if I am weak I go to the
most powerful if you know I I go to the
to the to the one who is all hearing who
could answer my calls 24/7 you know so
that is this is the basic that with the
risk of salvation and Islam now we if
you look at the any of you open the the
the Webster dictionary now and you see
what is the characteristics of God you
know God is perfect you know God is
all-powerful and anything beyond that it
takes away from the character of God you
know
so therefore if if God you know we say
sacrifice you know the act of sacrifice
you know is is is meaning when you look
at the word sacrifice it the Webster
dictionary meaning somebody have given
something for something else in return
so the question that we asked we ask
ourselves does God need to give up
something in return of something else no
I mean this is any of anybody whether
you know no matter what religious
background you come from
you know if you would deny this is such
of character to God even before that who
need to sacrifice for rule I mean this
is the question that we ask our fellow
human beings who need to sacrifice for
who you know we the one human beings
should be sacrificing to God you know
you know I am I am blessed full of all
the blessings that God have given me and
I am blessed that God had given me eyes
and have given me in a brain he have
given me senses so therefore you know
for me to appreciate what God have given
me I have to sacrifice to God to get his
pleasure but you know God does not need
to do the other way around in which that
he is sacrificing for me
he said I'm saying and I said and this
this is the concept of the basic concept
of you know of sacrifice you know in
Islam what if someone says look in the
old days they used to sacrifice animals
for God but now that's abrogated and
when Jesus came and he sacrificed
himself actually it gets confusing
because ok the people say Jesus is God
so God sacrificed himself basically like
committed suicide you would say right
how would you answer this yes this is
very easy question now if for meat
indeed one of the ways to get closer to
God is sacrifice and by the way who does
most of the sacrifice nowadays worldwide
toward God Muslims we sacrifice in the
time the Flickr image once a year in
order for us to be closer to God but the
question is is that the only way of
salvation toward God you know that's and
even that even mentioned in the in the
in the Bible in which that in the in the
in the book of Hosea 6:6 God says I I i
rather I would me I am I'm a God of
mercy rather than sacrifice so if you
want to get closer to God he rather to
forgive you another for you rather for
you to sacrifice for him
so therefore God he wants to he wants to
be he wants to forgive you if you ask
for he forgives for his forgiveness
he wants favor forgive you but it is not
it for every age in every action you
know to fully to sacrifice we should be
at the end of the day obeying what God
have
us to do you know and even when we
sacrifice something what is God gonna
gain from it you know yeah you know God
Almighty says in the Quran Lail Allah
honey daddy malakian Elohim income you
know there is a God when we sacrifice
animals what does God is going to gain
is he I mean God says he will not given
that in the meat is not gonna reach God
nor the blood is gonna reach God but
what is gonna reach God is our fear of
God our our the self righteousness that
you know the how much we fear that
that's what's going to you know that's
what God is gonna take from us you know
so uh sacrificing things it's it's it's
indeed one form but we should not put
all everything the only way for two
toward God is through sacrifice and what
forgot to sacrifice his own son who is
also considered God I mean it simply it
does it's the kind of contradictions so
it's through piety through righteousness
- humbleness - doing these things that
God told us to do obeying him and
seeking his pleasure doing the good
deeds that he's told us he don't need it
we need it but this shows our faith in
action and it makes sense and you make a
mistake and you turn to God alone you
don't need anybody nor did Jesus have
you found anywhere where Jesus said
explicitly listen or Moses or those that
came before him saying that listen Jesus
is coming God is coming in the form of a
man and then when Jesus came he should
have made this clear that look you have
to believe that I sacrificed my life for
you because this is salvation this is
your eternity paradise how far do we
find that happening the previous
prophets mentioning Jesus coming that
God is coming as a human being or Jesus
himself saying look I for you to gain
eternal paradise you have to believe
that I died for your sins that was never
mentioned and actually it was the
opposite throughout the Old Testament
and we did because think we as Muslims
we believe in the Bible the original by
all the Gospels you know we believe we
believe in the original preaching Moses
we believe the original bitching of
Jesus based upon them and so we have the
right to read the scriptures and see
what's what what goes along in our
belief on what contradicts our belief so
therefore if you look at the Old
Testament you will not see the
concept of salvation through you know a
sacrifice if one man does not even exist
it's nothing you know yes one of the
ways for instance you will see you know
Abraham try to sacrifice his own his son
that's fine but that's but that's not
the only way toward toward getting
salvation but in you test even a New
Testament actually the quite opposite I
mean even when God wanted to even
according to to the to the the book of
Matthew when when Jesus was about to be
put on a cross he was not even willing
to be crucified and he's and and and and
according to and and and according to
the book of Matthew said you know Lord
Lord while you have forsaken me so he
was not even willing you know rabbee
rabbee Lema sabachthani and I said
that's what I the way it sounds in
Aramaic you know so he was telling God
why are you doing this to me
don't let this cup pass in another verse
you know so he was not really willing to
be to be sacrificed you know and that
actually goes along with what the would
Muslim thing have happened to Jesus in
which that the the you know people
wanted to kill Jesus and God has you
know and God Jesus have plead to God to
be saved and God have saved you should
be upon him so amazing when you look
into it that Islam makes it clear and
you mentioned the previous books what
was given to Moses and its original to
Torah we accept we believe what was
given to Jesus the NGO and its original
we believe but these books been changed
they've been altered you guys have a
bumper sticker it says the Quran never
changed never alters so people can find
these facts not fiction in first part
not third party God is speaking direct
in the Quran compiled over 23 years like
no other book can you speak about it
unchanged and and this is what one of
the miracles of the of the of the Quran
is that it was preserved since day one
God has said you know and that in the
Quran that this book was not preserved
in one books it was preserved within the
chest of men and that you know you'll
see millions of people who have
memorized the book from from cover to
cover every single letter even the way
it sounds
you know how much we elongate some of
the letters it's it's it's miracle in
itself how the Koran was preserved until
nowadays you're not gonna see two
different copies if you go all the way
from Indonesia all over to Morocco you
know you're gonna own it you don't see
one version of the Quran and if you have
any other questions you can go ahead and
ask a Muslim you guys have a telephone
number set up and the website you know
you go to our website on which we have
it's a scone Salam calm at the bottom of
the page we have live chat if you have
any questions just go in there and
somebody's gonna be asking any questions
any fears any misconceptions come to the
Muslims and a Muslim is simply one who
has chosen to submit to the creator
alone just like Jesus did he was a
Muslim you guys actually did a billboard
said Jesus is a Muslim yes this is one
of our famous billboards was when we
started this organization and this is
again we're not trying to insult anybody
but this is part of our core belief in
which that we believe that Jesus
submitted himself to the will of God and
that's what the word Muslim is just like
all the rest of the prophets Moses
Abraham Noah Ishmael Joseph all of them
have submitted to the softe to the will
of God and that's what we believe as
Muslims and if you look at nowadays II
there is no one who tried to be like
Jesus more than the Muslims if you go
outside who dressed like the mother of
Jesus Muslims who have beers like Jesus
Muslims who pray like Jesus Muslims who
who believed in Jesus you know or or or
or they they even dressed like him you
know a one-piece type of clothing you
know Muslims so the thing is we have
tried to follow his steps because we
love him he's he's very close to our
hearts that's deep I mean it just makes
sense it makes it don't get spooked now
by the Arabic Jesus spoke Aramaic you
follow me it was a Semitic language but
in English one is defined to you it just
makes sense all the messengers of God
they submitted not to Jesus or to the
creation but to the Creator and that's
what a Muslim is if you have any
questions ask a Muslim and we'll see you
next time until then peace be with you
Islamic